. Today, we're going to be speaking with Douglas
Murray, who is the best selling author of
numerous books, including The Madness of Crowds,
The Strange Death of Europe.
It's great to have you on first and foremost.
Very good to be with you, David.
So we're having this conversation just a few
days before a major election here in the United
States, where there will be either another
four years of Donald Trump or not.
There will be either more Republican control
of the Senate or not.
And really, a lot of the next two, four, six
years in the United States depends on the
outcome of this election.
We've seen in other sort of Western Democratic
allies also sort of turning points or potential
inflection points in terms of a more nationalist
move or not.
I guess with you, where I would want to start
is what do you see as the state of conservatism
right now?
And does that relate in any way to Donald
Trump or is Donald Trump not really part of
that movement as some traditional conservatives
in the United States feel?
It's it's a broad and complex question, and
it needs a broad and complex answer.
I mean, the short answer is, I think there
has been slightly uncomfortable alliance in
recent years between Donald Trump and the
Republican Party and the broader conservative
movement in the US.
And whether that remains or uncomfortable
becomes more uncomfortable or leads to a tiresome,
terrible bloodletting.
Well, I suppose depend on whether or not he
wins the election.
Not many days time.
I think that there will be if he doesn't win
the election.
I think there'll be considerable going over
of exactly what it is that happened in the
last four years and more in American Republican
politics that allowed for this to happen.
If he does win, of course, that all changes
because everybody migrates towards victors.
And many people on the conservative side in
American politics, many people who were unsure,
for instance, about joining his administration
or being aligned with it in the first four
years may decide to make some peace with it.
Not everybody, but some more people will.
I don't think, by the way, that although there
is an attempt always by the international
media to always draw sort of clear lines,
you know, we always like it to be, you know,
the world's turning left or the world's turning
right.
And it never quite works like that.
I think there are trends you can see, but
I don't actually think that Donald Trump is
part of any broader conservative or right
wing tendency.
He is, whether you're a Meyera detractor or
one of the confused people in the middle.
I mean, he is a very unusual force.
I do not think he is in any ways replicated
in other countries.
He's not he's not replicated in my own country,
for instance, in the United Kingdom.
So it's very hard to draw broader lessons
away from Donald Trump.
Yeah, I completely agree with you that when
I look at Donald Trump and I look at what
we're sort of more traditional conservative
principles, I don't see anything there.
Sometimes by sheer odds, he will stumble across
something that sort of seems to fit.
And for the most part, I see kind of buffoonery
in a dark room stumbling around and sometimes
hitting a light switch.
But that sort of gets to maybe a more forward
looking question, which is I see you as someone
who, although I think we would, you know,
agree about a few things, sort of, but have
significant political disagreements.
I see your brand of conservatism as something
that is almost directly antithetical to most
of what Donald Trump's policy has been and
make.
My curiosity is.
Do you think that it makes sense for American
conservatives to align with Trump and sort
of you try to use him to the extent they can
to accomplish, for example, the confirmation
of judges, which which really has been a major
success for the Republican Party under Trump,
because he'll nominate whoever they tell him
to nominate?
Or is that dangerous for the future of your
own movement?
Well, first of all, I'm not a part of a movement.
Conservatism is a very tricky beast to last
sue because conservatives conserve different
things in different countries.
What conservatives are conserving in France
is different from what a conservative is conserving
in Britain or Belgium or Denmark, let alone
the United States or anywhere else.
It's not quite the same to that extent with
what's become known, I think erroneously as
liberalism or leftism, which tends to have
the same set of demands.
It's a virtue and device of the left.
I think conservatism is harder to.
To sum up like that is an international trend.
You're right.
By the way, that Donald Trump is unusual.
I don't think it's quite correct to say that
he has sort of nothing in common with conservatism
in the United States.
I mean, certain obvious aspects of his agenda
are very conservative.
He he advocates borders.
And now I mean, by the way, that's that didn't
used to be, you know, seen as being a particularly
right wing thing.
But it is it has become a conservative aspect
to be broadly against open borders or, you
know, more in favor of of of stricter immigration
policies.
I guess I don't listen.
I'm just not so sure that that is actually
what makes him stand out as conservative.
Because when I see the Democratic proposals,
you know, on Dacca, for example, or I get
into details about it, I'm not seeing anybody
advocating for open borders, free muleya of
labor.
I just don't see that.
Well, what has happened what has happened
is that the left in America and elsewhere
has been finding it increasingly hard to react
against a specific.
I think I agree with you.
Rather unusual narrative on the left wing.
Nevertheless, the left is finding it increasingly
hard to resist.
I mean, obvious things.
People who come to the US illegally, amnesties,
these sorts of things.
There has become a tendency.
I think it's it's a shame for the immigration
debate to be seen in the Left-Right demands.
It didn't used to be, of course, the people
on the left like Bernie Sanders, who used
to recognize the labor implications, more
of this sort of thing.
But we just don't get stuck on borders, the
time being.
My point is simply that the president has
a stricter policy than his opponents on immigration,
rather boasts about it, if anything.
He clearly advocates the law and order agenda
defending police rather than any truck with
people who say they want to defund them.
Look, I think, as I say, it's Donald Trump
is a very difficult person to draw any clear
lessons from, because obviously these things
that I've just mentioned, many others are
central to his platform.
They've been central to a lot of conservative
voters voting for him.
And yet he is a totally unusual beast in nature.
And I suppose that, you know, one of the sadnesses
to me of the last four years is been the unwillingness
to learn the lessons of what the electorate
might have been saying for years ago in voting
for somebody who so many people had so many
problems with, not least on his own side,
that if you voted in the United States, would
you be voting for Donald Trump's reelection?
One of the great pleasures of not being a
citizen of the United States is not having
to weigh in in any way on the fractional politics.
And so, as an outsider, I will dodge that
question.
So it's just not a question you answer.
It's not a question I answer.
I'm not an American.
And I don't presume to say how I would vote
if I was an American.
I wouldn't like to advise any Americans on
how they should vote.
I can see the eye, can see a lot of arguments
each way.
But I think unless you live in a country and
pay taxes in a country and experience the
life in that country, I think you have to
be very wary and saying how people in that
country should vote.
That's a lesson I think I would I'd love to
think talk more about that, because like,
for example, I was born in Argentina, but
I don't live there.
But I'm very comfortable saying if I did,
I would not have voted for the current president
or, you know, in Israel, I would not be a
supporter of Benjamin Netanyahu or in the
UK.
I would not be a supporter of Boris Johnson.
And, you know, I'm not suggesting to anybody
else that I know more than them or telling
them how to vote.
But what why is it that you find it inappropriate
to comment on something like that?
We're a few days out from the election.
I write on these issues, but I don't like
to opine on how people should vote.
I just don't do it.
That's interesting.
You know, it's it's just the principle on
it.
I do.
I primarily think that out, you know, outsiders
in a country shouldn't do that.
And what is the principle that leads you to
that conclusion?
Well, I think I just said it.
I don't think that if you don't live in the
country, don't pay taxes and much more.
But you really should on advising people in
any way how to vote, which obviously saying
how you would vote in a country that does
that.
But I think I mean, the one thing I would
say, obviously, is it's a it's a it's a very
tricky situation that your country, the United
States, is in now.
And I think that it's a very serious time,
not just to do with Donald Trump, I think
is a very serious time in American history
and a difficult corner that you're at.
To the extent that there is a sort of wing
of the electorate and this exists significantly
in online circles that cross country lines,
you see a sort of coalescing around certain
ideas about identity politics and free speech
suppression.
Sometimes it includes discussions of tech
monopolies or social media networks.
Sometimes the idea of a culture war is it's
sort of raised.
I think you sort of understand that the sort
of umbrella that I'm referring to.
How important do you think that is in relation
to what we sometimes consider the sort of
major policy debates around things like health
care?
You mentioned immigration, foreign policy.
Are these.
Do they overlap significantly?
Are these groups of people that are concerned
with very, very different things and aren't
as worried about those big policy questions?
What's the interaction there?
All of these things shift.
Don't they?
All the time.
Foreign policy in particular, which you mentioned,
is a good example.
There are there are parties that have been
very interventionist in the United States
and in the United Kingdom in my lifetime,
which within years become relatively isolationist.
You know, all of these things shift around.
No political party remains totally static,
albeit they like to give out the impression
very often they do.
And I think that it's very hard to draw these
trends across borders.
I think you're right.
I think one thing that is happening in all
of our countries clearly is that there is
this uncomfortable disconnect going on between
the let's see, the traditional political wars
which have always gone on and which always
will go on.
And then these these larger, you might even
say to some extent, deeper US sort of identity
issues that are going on underneath everybody.
These ones are and some people call these
culture wars and much more.
These are very tricky things for politics
to address because you can do them sort of
glibly.
You can sort of nod to them.
But most politicians find them very dangerous
to touch.
That's certainly the experience in my own
country, the British politics, is that there
are these deep issues which occasionally I
think of them like a sort of geezer.
They don't mean it in the Cockney Guy Ritchie
sentence.
I mean, there's a type of geezer thing that
happens where a moment allows the jet to come
up and suddenly everybody notices it and you
notice what's going on underneath.
One of the interesting things that happens
with the interaction of politics is what you
describe with this sort of online world is
that these things occasionally erupt and people
can sort of refer to them.
They don't know what to do with them otherwise.
I mean, you can have an issue.
Oh, I don't know.
There'll be a specific people.
I mean, I think a council culture is an interesting
one to think about where you've had a problem
with online now for a couple of years, there
have been, you know, all of these debates
happening about what does one have a right
to speak at a college or or not?
And what does it mean if there are protests?
And what about their speech?
And then it led over to where Donald Trump
has sent some of his wildly capitalized tweets,
where he talks about council culture.
It's sort of pushed slightly above the surface
into something.
Trump is talking about.
Is that maybe an example?
Yes, it is.
It is.
It's not a bad example.
I would say, again, it's it's a good example
in some ways because you have that row about
that specific thing.
For instance, should X person speak Y venue?
Yes, but you do.
But we struggle with this question of France's.
Why are so many people in our time finding
it so incredibly hard to hear a contrary opinion?
What would the limits of opinion be?
Can they be in the public sphere, the same
thing that they are online?
These are all questions that we've been forced
to.
More or less think about and very imperfectly
address because of the strange online world
which we all live with.
We're going
to pause my conversation with Douglas Murray
there.
The full interview will be available on our
YouTube channel very soon at YouTube dot com
slash The David Pakman Show.
We'll take
a quick break and
be back after this.